your moves anymore  and uh yeah  really not not an issue  yeah well i mean this game just  illustrates how brutal a chess is yeah  it's unbelievable that you you fight for  six hours finally you lose due to some  inaccuracy and under time pressure okay  finally making some some mistake which  is kind of inevitable  so i'm guessing that's gonna be it  yeah and i i think that probably  concludes uh  we'll do a bit of a round up but not  really a proper round up because there  are so many so many matches in here  finally finally the game is over as you  can see on your screens there  all the favorites won their matches but  there have been some board points  lost along the way  some of the matches which look like huge  upsets are probably not reliably scored